et douglas ça y est ce un professeur de
droit et spécialiste en sciences
politiques avec toute la cei est selon
joël mercier d'être en direct avec nous
sur rt france alors l'amérique toute
entière était dans l'attenté du verdict
verdict annoncé moins de 24 heures après
avoir entendu les ultimes arguments de
l'accusation et de la défense êtes vous
surpris par la rapidité des
délibérations oui c'est une supris un
imprévu un ongle jury comme jerry nom
des six et dans une matinée c'est fini
donc oui c'est une supprimer aussi une
soulagement parce qu'on a évité des
émeutes en mini apple s est peut-être et
quelque chose plus que tendue dans tout
le pays
ça a arrêté des feux d'artifice lors des
rixes ovine a été jugé coupable des
trois chefs d'accusation qui avaient été
retenus contre lui meurtre homicide
involontaire et violences ayant entraîné
la mort on sait que le jeu doit
prononcer sa sentence de huit semaines
il encourt d'ailleurs jusqu'à 12 ans de
prison mais une peine qui pourrait être
allongée rallonger s'il met registre a
conclu à l'existence de circonstances
aggravantes
est-ce que tout d'abord d'art et
chauvine peut faire appel de ce verdict
oui d'abord il a le doigt d'un appel
donc ça c'est un droit constitutionnel
et seulement il va faire tous les toits
accusations parce que ça ne mange pas de
pain pourquoi pas mais les appels exige
qu'il y ait des procédures elle et on
n'était pas content du tout d'y aller
irrégularités donc l'appel peut être
d'irritants prolonger plus les peines et
ça pourrait jouer dans son faveur
un petit peu dommage mais au fond d' ce
sera deux mois un décennie
dans une prison et peut être plus
ea pour les policiers être en prison
c'est très dangereux ce soit concernant
directement
alors justement est ce qu'on peut
considérer ce jugement comme une
victoire contre les violences policières
hommes oui si molik morts mais
précisément les simpson ne vont pas
changer des choses sur seulement un
message est net et clair que
l'utilisation d'une telle force pourrait
être sanctionné mais juste 20 minutes
avant le verdict une fille a été tuée
par les polices dans la même ville mini
apps laisse avec et des hommes
d'affaires
victoire symbolique ne suffisent pas
dernière question de glace hayette
j'aimerais que l'on parle aussi de la
réaction de joe biden puisque le
président américain a pris la parole
depuis la maison blanche
il a appelé d'ailleurs la mairie qu'elle
se rassembler à lutter contre le racisme
qui je cite en entache son âme
c'était important justement que le
président américain appelle d'abord la
famille de georges feuilles puis
prennent la parole ensuite pour
s'adresser aux américains
oui on peut regarder ça donne deux sens
le premier recensé juste politique
politicienne
un essayer de gagner des pointes dans
l'électrique noir c'est une vision
cynique ici important de poggio by day
mais un autre façon de le regarder ces
deux familles des victimes
georges fleury qu'ils ont leur peine
reconnu et que le cul miniter aussi soir
au camp nou
d'un point de vue politique oui mais
aussi sensibilité envers les victimes de
glace ça y est merci beaucoup d'avoir
répondu à nos questions ce matin je
rappelle que vous êtes professeur de
droit et spécialiste de sciences
politiques américains